live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions it's the Dave Ramsey show
where dead is dumb cash is king and the
paid off on mortgage has taken the place
of the BMW as the status symbol of
choice yeah that vinyl scratchy opener
of Baker Street you know what that means
by now you've been hearing it off and on
throughout the summer means we're going
to take a little bit of time and walk
down memory lane celebrating our 25th
anniversary here of the Dave Ramsey show
and we appreciate all of you hanging out
with us and so we're taking a segment
every so often or two ever so often and
just discussing the past talk about
funny things fun things that have
happened and a little bit of walk down
memory lane some of it a little bit
poignant but most of it not and this
hour joining me the original producer of
the Dave Ramsey show now sitting on our
operating board and is the really in
charge of all things production here at
Ramsey solutions Blake Thompson Laura
Johnson was hired originally to do phone
screening also dealt with affiliates a
little bit a little bit of an assistant
to the vice president at that time of
radio bill Hampton and then later became
an associate producer working the phones
and so forth and now runs up all of our
video production here as far as
broadcast video production stuff that it
goes to air with and so welcome you too
hi thank you so the three of us have
done tens of thousands of hours of this
show together but 100 percent of those
were with both of you or at least one of
you the other side of the glass this is
the first time all three of us have set
on this side of Michael right first time
ever that want to go over the last after
this right
there's a reason yes that's absolutely
why that was the case so very very fun
so let's kind of go back to the old days
I mean Blake comes on board and we've
talked about this with each of you being
on there separately and then just me
telling stories and stuff Blake comes on
board um gets his dream job so this
meeting he thought it was
and uh turned into a nightmare and then
turns into a dream and then turned into
a nightmare and turned into a dream then
Laura comes on I told her she could she
wouldn't mean enough to thank phone
screening it turns out she was yes yeah
I was filming Phyllis just asked the
people to work on her team but uh but uh
you know I said to the other day I think
when Laura was on the air Blake that I'm
convinced one of the reasons and you and
I have talked about this several times
over the years one of the reasons this
show has been so successful is that the
three of us working together got to
where we could finish each other's
sentences we just look through the glass
and we knew what each other meant right
and and it dialed in because in the
radio business or so many big egos and
low paychecks and everything else it
overnight they turn over like underwear
yeah so I mean the fact that the three
of us for a good 17 years on the 25 were
in there I think the stability of that
gave us the ability to build and build
and build and build and build our depth
of what we were doing on the air in
terms of creating compelling radio and
it was an it was an advantage we had
over over other shows that we didn't
even realize right three hours a day
Monday through Friday when we finally
moved from the little studio the little
closet from the local radio station and
built our first studio debt-free it was
like two offices and we knocked the wall
out in the middle and put a little glass
and like you said we we decided we need
a phone screener
that was on our team and Laura was
assisting the but one of our vice
presidents at the time and like you said
we were like can she do this and she had
a background actually in broadcast yeah
got a degree I'm actually working with
my degree yes yeah and she had a mandate
yeah she would that's why I kind of why
she we gave her the chance because she
was like this that's what I was wanting
to do so we put on the phones and she
learned it quick like to your point Dave
it was a great mix of three hours a day
every day her learning how to screen and
put on the right people that you could
help and the biggest part of that and
phone screen and Laura you can jump into
this about how you do it so well is
um not only are we helping the person
that called but she did such a great job
of making sure the topic they're talking
about touch more than just the person on
the phone hi as we grew and got bigger
in the head we were playing to an
audience when we had a lot of people
that we were trying to help not just
that one so we just used that one in
that particular situation to help masses
of people yeah and then you mix the
chemistry of the bump music on music
that Dave grew up with in the 70s and
maybe in a music fan and I think there's
an element of bump even still today with
James that we get common in all the time
out the music it's part of that
chemistry it's the great calls it's the
great music it's of course the host yeah
and so yeah it was just the right people
together
Friar's um you know yeah you're you're
back with some bump music a after a
coffee and a propane made that was
completely inappropriate many people
laugh for money I think the only one I
can really say on air travel is a woman
called one time and was like really
upset because um I guess she was going
through a divorce or split board with a
boyfriend and he was becoming a little
stalkerish and was like not leaving her
alone and all that we went to the break
with um the police's every breath you
take I'll be watching you
yeah he's like that yes that maybe
sometimes like it I would it would be a
private joke to say I wasn't able when I
emailed and Twitter later and nowaday
yeah James gets a few of those like that
but James mostly gets compliment is nice
and he does it too so for those of you
Elizabeth yeah they're not listening
with that filter it's a subtle message
in some of the bump music after a car
not to settle yeah a brick through a
window oh my gosh we're talking about
Blake Thompson Laura Johnson the
original producer and phone screen on
the Dave Ramsey show for about 17 years
they're both in our executive and
leadership team now and both sitting in
seats where they lead creative folks and
lead entire projects around this kind of
stuff for instance James and Kelly on
this show
work they report directly to Blake
regarding this show and production
elements here as an example Laura runs
all of the YouTube channel and the Dave
Ramsey show app channel as well so all
that live stream video and those that
whole crew that runs all of that
produces all those YouTube bits the
turning-point bits and all of that and
the millionaire stuff we're doing and
all that Lara's picking her team does
every bit of that and so you know we're
just kind of going to go walking down
memory lane just a little bit here and
yeah there's been some stuff happen over
the years definitely yeah we've learned
everything everything we have a big team
now in fact in the day it was the three
of us why is it just us and part of that
is being thrown in the fire to learn
stuff part of that is your drive of like
we talked about last time we were
together Dave about hey we might not
know exactly how to do it but we're
going to do it and one of those things
that comes with that is is learning
things by just falling into them like we
tried to do a remote one time Dave
wanted to do a remote over in Tennessee
somewhere by a not know South I'd
Memphis or something anyway at a
bookstore first one it was first for me
and Dave's on the other end and he's
hearing himself back right when we start
and he's like Blake and he's on the air
live like this isn't going to work we're
going to best up in three two one
what's the best tough and and I don't
have any tape ready to go so I do not
leave the mic on okay and Washington
yeah it's broken yeah so now we do
remotes like anywhere we go
we have that stuff's every day we have
full-time guy doing best does but yeah
that's a good example of that we'll be
running on the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
anniversary theme our well our theme
segments for a few minutes here Blake
Thompson former producer now senior
producer executive senior producer what
do we call that hesitation
c-3po we humpin but um that's right that
makes the r2d2 I'm Jason yeah a lot of
Johnson is with us as well they were the
original producer and phone screener for
17 years or so here on the air and yeah
you don't do 25 years of radio without
making some mistakes yes go ahead Laura
okay
that there's a ton of them I mean no
time I mean yeah yeah come on but you
have this very uncanny ability to do
some audience lips maybe some word
associations just the wrong time wrong
wrong wrong and we would have we had a
lady you call in I do
for some reason they stuck in my because
I was so shocked we thought about doing
a book of them we might be up they said
what that's a book but um yeah a lady
called in and her husband had been hit
by a car he was riding his bike and she
had life insurance money and she was
trying to figure out what to do you know
she'd paid off some things and it's time
to invest and you're walking her through
some investing things and you go you
know investing once you get it it's just
like riding a bike we all just kind of
froze like why would he say yeah and
another one a soldier called in and he
had stepped on a landmine and he was
disabled now and he'd know exactly what
he's going to do and you're walking him
through how to better jobs he can find
and he said you know you get back up and
put one foot in front of again we were
shocked and amazed like what is
happening but the last one that I
remember is them another lady had called
in and her husband had been swimming in
the ocean he drowned and we're I know
that's why I guess it was so it was so
shocking but and she was walking through
life insurance and all that all that and
you were being so understanding of
darling I know
tough time you're just trying to keep
your head above water we all are like oh
wow what's happening I look I would look
up and there's a Raiders of wall that's
about four and a half feet tall that
then they said it high bar stir those
type things in the studio and I would
look up and it was like walking on what
wacom oh no oh yes drop that was there
later laughing so hard he was sitting in
the border laughter I'm like what is so
funny couldn't see us where you had done
something funny Oh Stephen to be fair to
be fair it was not like I learned that
the guy drowned no then 30 seconds later
it's four or five minutes down in the
menthol yeah I circle back and usually
exactly wrong metaphor ah yes you made a
connection it's like there's a bunch of
those now it's just that's what we're
starting it really involved industry so
shocking but yes Kelly and James
sometimes bring us more under the leaf
there's that yeah and you used to do ads
on the air and usually to read them live
we would do ad libs you don't even want
him copy is that libs and I wait and you
would riff and you would nail it you'd
watch the clock and you could get ad
done in a minute
exactly not not 58 seconds not in it to
you but again you get to go and get
flowing and it was Christmas time along
and we had all live and we had Randy
Parker with a diamond seller here in
Nashville were advertising for and he
said it's Christmas you said most that
time of year again we're chestnuts are
roasting on an open fire and if you need
to get your chestnuts out of the fire
fuzzy fiber glass sometimes your face is
priceless because you knew you said and
you were like I don't know yeah you
can't yeah you can't I'm sure that Mel
oh you're in trouble my favourite is
there was a woman that was won the Lisa
Cardinals honking talk anyway and yeah
if it's inappropriate it's on me it's
all inappropriate she was wanting to
lease a car and Dave's like don't you
lease that car I'm telling you right now
do not lease that car you promise me you
won't lose that car right when we're
going to break and she says I promise
you guys if I find out you lease that
car I'm gonna come down there and jump
your bones that's not good that's not
what you like comes out right now you
know what that means
pretty soon and I have to talk to Dave
about this I have to tell him you can't
say that that's not what that means you
know the second I walk and I go did you
know and you look at me go I get it I
didn't mean to say that I know what it
means
classic yes that was clutch yeah that
ladies out there wandering range don't
worry I was Dave Rancic I'm terrified
I'm terrified agree oh my gosh when we
used to even in this studio when we
first moved into this studio even back
further than that we would allow people
to come and just special guests and sit
in the studio they had to like know
somebody or my or they were a Financial
Peace University coordinator and all new
employees remember that horrible
recording was I had to come and sit in
our hello and be punished yet with
loosening of the show yeah I mean and
they would be sitting they were sitting
right here I mean there's no glasses
right in which was dumber than crime
when we look back I mean we're like
that's no no you don't in it no one in
broadcast how does that kind of stuff
nothing but we've got to sit not just
behind the glass they were in here with
me and so if they like start laughing it
would go over the air or they are doing
some know something else you're stopped
right right after this yeah we have
understand why our tube is like this
isn't a good idea but we have guests in
here sitting down and Dave's doing the
show we're in the middle of the longest
segment of the show I'm screaming phone
calls I can see the guests back of their
heads and
I look up and this guy is kind of
leaning over kind of looks like he was
laughing about what's he laughing it and
then all of a sudden I see Dave pick up
a trash can as calm as can be reach over
the desk and hand it home here told me
all you're talking to the question you
know you hand him the trash can and then
I'm like oh he's getting sick right
there in the studio with ever you know
on national radio
he is getting sick no studio he didn't
get it in the trash he had already
started when you handed the trash that
was kind of magical courtesy yeah and
now he does really good face you know
and then yet the got the guy's face when
he realizes hard I mean it was so
embarrassing I came by here you know
that entre series yeah he stopped my
hero he goes I don't know if you
remember me or not I was like no I'm the
guy throughout the studio no oh yes
remember you yes we do yes you're the
reason no one else is in this room
except for Dave ever again we have an
admin assistant crazy come down and just
clean that whole thing during the play
you're number four yes crew yeah trying
to get everything out so you can stay in
here with the smell it was unbelievable
oh yeah I'm always when I do that I
always think about I had to quit saying
it was kind of like that Freudian thing
because I always say you know what the
callers like hey what's up mark tell me
what's up
and then if their name was Chuck I was
awesome I would say it almost cracked up
and poor Chuck he's probably had that
his whole life so Terrell it's just you
know the mix - thing we went into the
break with that is if you guys out there
don't know what that is I didn't know
what it was like on the radio but
apparently when you're sending your
signal from one studio to another and
you know it takes a few seconds to get
there and it comes back now in your
headset
you're hearing yourself three to five
seconds later and there's nothing more
distracting in the world you cannot you
it's like yeah you're it's like patting
your head and rubbing your stomach
they're almost impossible to think and
all yes while you're hearing yourself
back five seconds later very clearly in
your headset and so you
we're I go on the air that's going on
for a little while and I just thought
there's no possible way I can just I
can't and so I'm like okay like we are
going to best stuff I guess yeah three
two one right having that stuff yeah
yeah we did have any best selves and now
we have a guy Jack Bennett that all he
does a lot of things but is number one
key result areas listen to the show
every day for anything he catches it's
maybe a date Dave mentions or something
we don't want to re air and archives
those and so whenever Dave's out you
usually don't know he's out he does such
a good job editing so yeah that's
actually the best segment so it's
actually better or not is you're all
thinking I am mad because you know you
always get the best segment when I am
here like Thompson Laura Johnson
congratulations you guys on all these
years of serving gradualist we
appreciate if I hear appreciate all
you've done and hopefully we didn't end
it right here but yeah thanks for the
opportunity I'll be your last time on
the air right they are butter 25-year
celebration on the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]